ladies hello hi how's it going
good good how are you yeah how are you
good i'm good
so zazzy back in like a superhero comic
book worlds
again what is it that appeals to you so
much about these stories
um i think that superhero stories are
really just um
a heightened way to tell really human
stories you know i think it's
about being different being um
being unique in a world and how to
grapple with that you know i think like
x-men is a really great example of that
but then also in this sort of
instance you know mark is a teenager
going through changes it's a
coming-of-age story and
i think like anybody transitioning into
adulthood um
there's a lot to be reckoned with and i
think those
feelings and emotions um are just sort
of
amplified in in like a superhero setting
and so
um yeah i just think they're i think
they're often just really
relatable yeah
that's true so gillian how do you
prepare to voice a superhero what
training did you put yourself through
to voice superhero yes going back to all
the vocal exercises
i learned in acting school warming up
the voice
making sure i have enough to drink in
the booth
um and then saving all the yelling
for the end of the session it's my voice
that would be by uh i guess the
preparation i did
but it must get your ego up a little bit
right you get to play a superhero
i was just a voice yeah it was really
fun
yeah and so
i wouldn't say that 2021 is like a
winning year for a lot of people but
you are winning 2021 because you got
this coming out you got
the harder they get coming out with that
insane cast of regina king
jr salvador lindo you're in bullet train
and we just saw this first photo of brad
pitt sandra bullock on set together
give me the scoop like have you shot
scenes with sander brad like what's
going on here
um i i have already i've done my bullet
train thing
um and i um
i didn't get to shoot with um sandra but
i did get to shoot with brad and um i
mean it was
it was so fun it's a great fun set
um and i had to you know i i think at
that point i had already worked on like
a covent set and so
my expectations around that um you know
we're already set and
um you know so i was able to just i
think lean in it's a fun story and i was
able to lean in and just sort of have a
good time and
yeah i have i have the heart of the fall
coming out and i'm i'm really excited
about that it's a really special
cast and um you know i think the stories
is i think people are gonna have a lot
of fun with it but it's also like
grounded and real and there's emotions
and it's heightened it's a lot of stuff
and so
um yeah i you know i'm i'm looking i'm
looking forward to working and
uh you know yeah it's gonna be working
out
and both of you have been part of
projects that are very passionate
fan bases so gillian do you feel
prepared for that passionate robert
kirkman
fan base that's going to come at you
with this oh i hadn't thought about that
until you just said that
oh sorry no i mean i i've been lucky
enough yeah to be a part of a show that
has a really passionate and enduring fan
base um
and it's been an incredible experience
and
taught me really what um a show can mean
to people and what these characters can
mean to people
and so um i i hope that the fans of the
comic love this show
i think we all feel not to speak for
anyone else but i feel
um like it's a terrific show
and i think because robert is so
involved
in the animated series um hopefully it
will
feel like the comic that they all love
right
right and speaking of fan bases can you
give me like a one sentence tease for
fear street
because people are very excited gillian
oh um
oh this is the first time you're
catching me with all these questions
i've never been asked before
it's going to be really good and there's
three of them there you go yeah
the scoop right there and
zazzy just just finally um i found it so
refreshing about the show and
kind of weird that it is refreshing that
uh the characters the ethnicities of the
characters
are voiced by those same mechanisms
which we haven't always seen in
animation and obviously that's been a
very big conversation the last couple
years was that something that stood yet
stood out to you in this project that
there was
proper representation going on in the
voice cast
um yeah you know i think also you know
specifically with my character
um she was um changed in the comics
she's white and
in the sh in the series in the show oh
yeah okay it's black
and so um you know i think it i think it
is good you know i think
not only sort of opening doors for other
people and actors to
you know have space in the room um you
know i think it's
it it is i think you know appropriate to
do and so
um you know i'm i'm really glad that
invincible
sort of has um you know that the leads
are even just
or um just different
you know that stephen yoon is a part of
this and um
and um oh my gosh senator oh and
uh you know that it's not just sort of i
think a basic i think a lot of
people a lot of um superhero characters
are
are white and um i think it's great to
shake that up because there are many
different kinds of people in the world
so amen well congratulations i love the
first three episodes i can't wait to see
more congratulations on the show
yeah have a great day thank you